joining me now is the former secretary
of labor under bill clinton
a berkeley economist professor robert
reich he's also the author of the book
the system
who rigged it how we fixed it uh robert
pleasure to have you on the show
we're about to be treated to another
round of we can't afford it from
born again deficit hawks in the
republican party who haven't cared
one bit about deficit spending under
donald trump putting their hypocrisy to
one side for a moment
do explain to our viewers why it is so
important for biden administration to go
big on spending
and why adding to the debt is not a big
deal right now
well first of all you say putting their
hypocrisy to one side if you put
hypocrisy to one side there's nothing
left i mean basically the republican
party today
true not true is the epitome of
hypocrisy i mean they gave a two
trillion dollar tax cut to the wealthy
uh and to big corporations
and they never talked about deficits
they never ever ever talked about debt
and now suddenly it's all about deficits
and debt once again
predictably that's happened every single
time a democratic administration has
come in
and they're doing it now even before the
democratic administration has come in
look you ask why is it so important to
spend now it's important to spend and we
understand this this is economics 101
because if you've got so many people
unemployed if you've got
basically a lot of a lot of businesses
that are going under one-third of small
businesses are no longer there
i mean you've got to rely on government
as the spender of last resort we
understood this we understood this
in the 1940s 50s 1960s richard nixon
of all people he said we're all
keynesians now
referring to the doctrine that i just
enunciated that we
do have to rely on government spending
uh and you don't
you don't worry about debt there is not
even a whiff of inflation in the air you
can't find inflation
anywhere you look under your under your
bed look in the closet
there is no inflation so let's not worry
about the possibility
of the economy overheating right now it
is critical
that we make these kinds of public
expenditures
to keep to help people survive that's
what we're talking about fundamentally
here we're talking about
survival well well put well put indeed
one bone of contention in this quote
unquote partisan stimulus debate that we
often report on in the media
has been federal funding for local and
state governments you talk about people
surviving it's often
at the grassroots community level
republicans have generally opposed most
of it but we're learning
uh the costs of that now first there's
the lack of local infrastructure to
administer
covert vaccines when they become
available and now you have this
situation where we're learning about for
example
the washington dc metro has a half a
billion dollar
budget shortfall if it doesn't receive
more federal funding it will need to
shed more jobs
cut bus routes close train stations
all of which impacts the larger
workforce amplify that across the
country
and it's a disaster even for
republican-run states republican-run
communities
well that has never stopped the
republican party before
i mean look at medicaid medicaid
expansion a lot of republican governors
said we don't want it
and then they were told well wait a
minute the federal government is going
to pick up
almost all of this expenditure and it's
your people who are going to be
given or at least have access to health
insurance you're critically important
and nevertheless the governors of
republican states said no we still don't
want it
look the the point is that state and
local governments are critical
in terms of fighting kovid they're
critical in terms of getting the economy
back on track
we're talking about millions of people
who are teachers
and police officers social workers fire
uh fighters
uh people who are first responders if
they don't get
if they can't keep their jobs and we've
already lost a lot of them because
states
can run deficits by their own state
constitutions almost every one of them
says no deficits so the federal
government has got to
help the states out for the for the sake
of the public
yeah robert what do you make of the
biden economics team of janet yellen at
treasury
near a tandem at the budget office are
they progressive enough
ambitious enough for your liking i mean
there's no sign of an elizabeth warren
or a bernie sanders in his cabinet not
yet at least
uh no there's no fire brand i mean i i
hope
and that somebody like elizabeth warren
or bernie sanders
gets there gets into the cabinet
although they're very valuable where
they are as well
let's make no mistake about that uh but
uh the the biden
administration the ins in cohen biden
administration
i think is going to be uh certainly had
the right values there's no question
about that
the question that to my mind is the same
as i asked and many people asked about
the obama administration
how aggressive are they willing to be
how bold are they willing to be
particularly
when they have to deal with a republican
congress uh and
unless those two georgia seats are
flipped on january 5th
uh the republicans mitch mcconnell are
still going to be in charge
of the senate yes
and of course joe biden has a lot of
plans if he can get that senate majority
in addition to continuing coveted
stimulus
he's proposed some other economic
proposals for working people
including raising the minimum wage to 15
and for giving
some amount of student loan debt
yesterday robert you tweeted quote
if we can cancel trillions in taxes for
a handful of billionaires
we can cancel student loan debt for 45
million
students do you think the biden plan for
student loan forgiveness goes
far enough uh what should he be doing on
this in your view
i think it could go farther he's talking
about up to ten thousand dollars
of student loan forgiveness uh i am i i
think
elizabeth warren hit it right maybe
fifty thousand uh and
graduated according to family income but
you see one of the advantages here when
you're dealing with federal student loan
debt
uh the president can do this
cancellation by executive order
he doesn't need to wait for mitch
mcconnell or the republicans if they
still have a kind of a veto
or power over the over the senate or
over the president's
agenda uh he can do this and it would be
a huge stimulus we have
a huge number of people obviously who
owe student debts
they are not just uh within years of of
having graduated
some of them are middle-aged some of
them in fact i ran into somebody
recently
uh a uh somebody who was on social
security
a retiree uh she said to me you know my
retirement checks are being my social
security checks are being garnished
by the federal government because i was
a co-signer of my daughter's student
debt my student loan debt uh 10 years
ago well this is absurd
uh particularly when we're going into
the uh the the
the double dip or or triple you could
say triple dip
of a for increasing covid and also
all of the other problems we've been
talking about no student debt can
and should be at least if not eliminated
entirely
up to 50 000
yeah completely agree uh one last
question before we run out of time i do
want to talk about billionaires for a
minute
uh specifically one billionaire tesla
ceo elon musk a few months about you
tweeted that he was a quote
modern day robber baron for cutting
workers wages while his own net worth
quadrupled to 100 million dollars
uh during the pandemic uh quadruple by
100 million dollars doing the panama he
responded by saying his workers get
stuck
so it evens out he called you a quote
modern day [ __ ]
uh putting aside the name calling for a
moment and the fact that so many
billionaires
are such big babies do you buy his
argument
that it all evens out with stock options
especially at a time of
rising inequality and billionaires like
musk getting richer
during this pandemic uh he's now the
second richest man
in the world right now uh and it doesn't
make any sense he has fought unions
he has fought safety features in his own
factories
uh he is not reporting on the degree of
covid but we have reason to believe that
there has been a lot of covid
uh he basically thumbed his nose at
public officials
who wanted to go slow with regard to
reopening factories he said i'm going to
reopen my factory anyway
you you can't play fast and loose uh
with with organized
with workers whose lives are at stake uh
who want to organize unions who want to
actually get some piece of the action
and i think that uh elon musk uh
well i i won't say he's a modern day of
[ __ ] he isn't uh he can he can call me
whatever names he wants
but i do think he's a he's a modern-day
robber baron because we're but we're
back
in the second gilded age we're back
where they where we were 120 years ago
with robber barons
who didn't really care about their
workers who didn't care about widening
inequality
didn't care about the consequences of
their spending
on politics and on the corruption of
government uh elon musk
is a representative of the modern robber
baron mentality
that infects so much of america today
i'm afraid you're right about that
there's definitely the infecting of
america today
robert reich we appreciate you taking
time out thank you so much for coming on
the show